what's wrong what's wrong with uh having
100 of cars being EVS the problem with
that okay a couple of days first of all
what's wrong with that here's what's
wrong with it Biden Administration right
now is trying to build a national
charging station powered by the
government and funded by the government
and all over the the problem with that
is Henry Ford didn't Envision a
nationalized gas system what does that
mean if you have a ban the internal
combustion engine and then you only have
a national especially a Powertrain or
you have to plug in your house which is
going to be huge uh electricity bill
increase you're gonna have the
government will have the power to turn
off this electricity number one they can
stop movement but more importantly when
you're plugging in and charging your EV
not only are you relying more on China
for all the rare earth mining the Cobalt
and for other components but you're also
literally charging your car currently on
40 50 80 fossil fuel say it's a cold car
it's a natural gas car it's an oil car
depending on where you live and what
your local gen generation is so it's
just kind of it's a weird nonsensical
transfer people think oh I have an
electric car I don't need fossil fuels
I'm sorry and how are you plugging it in
where's the energy Michael Moore laid
this out brilliantly and planted the
humans he said oh everyone's for solar
and wind electric cars but where's that
energy coming from and he would show
like the solar panel displays they'd
pull the curtain back like in The Wizard
of Oz and show the diesel generators
running the power at its back up behind
the scenes so
uh but an electric car if you want to
get one fine I personally will never buy
one because I dive stick shift until
they come up with at least a faux stick
shift in an electric car I have no
interest in it but there's nothing wrong
an electric car I know people have
Teslas they love them in that regard but
don't try to sell them as Planet saving
and don't mandate it and don't use them
to get rid of you know internal
combustion cards but beyond that
huge number of government reports
academic U.S information agency all
these reports coming out calling for the
abolition of Private Car ownership which
is where I think this is ultimately
going to go Andrew Yang the Democrat
president I believe you interviewed him
like three weeks before weeks ago
he he actually during the campaign when
he's running for president said he went
to
possibly look at eliminating Private Car
ownership and instead turning to roving
Fleet of rental electric cars for people
that is where I think they want to go
with this in an electric car because and
there's also reports and I haven't been
able to verify this but that Elon Musk
should try to de-power or turn off the
the his cars that are in Russia as a
punishment to the Russian citizens for
living under Putin but the idea that you
you have to pay a subscription for
certain elements is for certainly the
self-driving parts of Tesla you're
getting into this corporate government
merger where your life's going to be
more dependent one of the things that
the automobile I.E the the internal
combustion engine gave Americans was
Freedom the freedom to move freedom of
movement freedom to drive same way with
cheap air travel they're they're going
after that hard under a declared climate
emergency you can only fly when it's
morally justifiable uh you can in France
are already eliminating short haul
flights due to CO2 uh in the United
States they are they are literally
talking about flying once or twice a
year and all these government reports
and I detail these are in peer-reviewed
journal these are in academic reports
it's very clear where they want to go
with so they've got this thread of CO2
and they're using it for everything the
same way they use the threat of a virus
to shut down churches and backyard
barbecues and weddings and funerals but
hey Walmart was open and hey Amazon was
making a lot of money and hey go on
online and Facebook
this is part of their agenda they need
crises and that's it's about crisis
declaration if you go back in history
the Roman Republic descended into an
Empire from abuse of emergency Powers
Middle Ages saw centralization of power
Germany 1933 the abuse of emergency
Powers the Patriot Act abuse of
emergency Powers which essentially is
leading to all the Banning of you know
free speech today
but this is the world we face now they
want to declare a National Climate
emergency they want to have a pandemic
treaty which is the most frightening
thing modeled after this U.N climate
ipcc report that's where we're headed
right now
with the coven climate merging of issues
and Bill Gates is expert Bill Gates is
calling it germ Bill Gates single
biggest funder to World Health
Organization they want a pandemic treaty
where Bill Gates paid experts can
declare a viral emergency shutdown
essentially the world in a whim you can
get rid of your outliers like Sweden or
or
Ron DeSantis make us all beholden to
some Global treaty where we have to go
on it that's what's scary they tried for
decades on climate utterly failed that's
why they went after kids the cold Greta
thunderberg movement was the climate's
activists realization that they failed
to convince adults so they went after
kids and they did a pretty good job with
kids to scare them so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]